[Musica]
26 11 2001 all'ospedale di forlì non
usciva questa piccola bambina fragile
come un soffione quando tira il vento
aveva i capelli neri come la pece così
lunghi che ricoprivano completamente le
orecchie gli occhi erano di un nero così
nero che era impossibile distinguere la
pupilla dalli ride e si aveva paura a
guardarli perché sembrava di cascarci
dentro e perdersi per sempre come se
fossero un buco nero quella bambina ero
io sì ben capelli e gli occhi sono
sbiaditi negli anni ma sono ancora così
diversa
basta guardarmi per capire che non sono
italiano eppure io mi sono sempre
sentita tale ed è proprio qui che sono
iniziati i problemi
ricordo però che la mia primissima
infanzia non fu brutta per niente il
merito di ciò va sicuramente a quelli
ingenua stupidità infantile di cui io
personalmente ero piena non vedevo la
cattiveria nelle persone non sentivo la
solitudine che mi avvolgeva amavo andare
all'asilo ed ero sempre allegra però
all'asilo non aveva amici giocavo da
sola o meglio con i miei amici
immaginari
perché se ogni bambino ne ha uno io ne
avevo un intera gang che vi assicuro che
spaccava quando non recitavo stavo in un
angolino ad esercitarmi a scrivere
lettere e numeri dentro quadratini
sempre più piccoli perché l'ordine
rigore mi avevano sempre tranquillizzata
e la voglia di impegnarmi non mi era mai
mancata ricordo che facevo proprio
fatica interagire con gli altri bambini
perché non sapevo l'italiano conoscevo
due parole anche quelle le pronunciamo
male quindi era davvero complicato però
ero riuscito a farmi odiare quanti
dispetti mi facevano gli altri bambini
ora che sono grande riflette dico come
strano per amarsi
bisogna conoscersi invece per odiarsi
questo non serve anzi paradossalmente è
proprio all'ignoranza che genera l'odio
io credo che i pregiudizi non siano
cattivi
il male sta nell'odio basato su questi
definendo ragioni i pregiudizi
mi stupisco come lame del passato non
abbia mai perso la speranza
il sorriso nonostante tutto e tra alti e
bassi
i tre anni dell'asilo finirono arriva il
momento di andare alle elementari
io ero entusiasta non vedevo l'ora di
imparare cose nuove e poi ero pronta
sapevo contare fino a cento
sapevo scrivere leggere lettere e numeri
sapevo i nomi dei mesi so che voi giorni
della settimana mi aveva insegnato mia
mamma con tanta pazienza lavorandoci
tutti i pomeriggi c'era solo un problema
e sapeva in inglese
io credo che la cosa più difficile che
abbia mai fatto in vita mia sia stato
imparare l'alfabeto in italiano
non ce la facevo proprio a dire c invece
dissi era così complicato e a tutto
questo si aggiunge il fatto che gli
amici non ne avevo ancora e adesso i
bambini non si limitavano a strapparmi
il gioco di mano
no le sue parlavano insultavano e
stavolta li capivo e quasi rimpiangevo
di saper l'italiano perché essere
ignorante sarebbe stato meno doloroso
come spesso succede
tutti mi definivano l'indiana e io non
lo sopportavo perché indiana io sono
italiana sono nata qui sono cresciute a
p
vivo qui qui in italia io mi sentivo
profondamente italiana ma agli occhi
degli altri
era la mia origine indiana a
caratterizzarli e allora pensai se
voglio uscire da questa identità ne devo
creare un'altra più forte c'erano due
opzioni o diventavo la bambina più
cattiva e monella di tutti o diventato
la più brava
scelsi la seconda perché i miei genitori
mi hanno insegnato che nella vita
bisogna sempre aver il coraggio di fare
la scelta più difficile più coraggiosa
se davvero si vuole arrivare una meta e
sicuramente mi deve aver aiutato
qualcuno da lassù a trovare quel
coraggio a quell'età
mi impegna il doppio rispetto agli altri
anzi il triplo perché io non sono mai
stata una persona particolarmente
intelligente io avevo e ho solo voglia
di impegnarmi e alla fine ce la feci
diventai la migliore della classe ma
quello stemma non riuscì a togliermelo
ero ancora l'indiana brava sì anzi
bravissima ma indiana addirittura la mia
origine indiana era infatti data dall
andare bene a scuola un indiana che va
meglio degli italiani incredibile ma io
non volevo essere diversa o speciale
volevo solo essere come tutti gli altri
gli altri loro sembravano di armi ancora
di più ora che andavo meglio di loro
come se avessi fatto un torto perché la
vita è una sfidano e durante le
elementari feci uno dei miei primi
viaggi in india ed ero contenta ho fatto
un viaggio così lungo ero stata in un
posto così lontano però l'idea di essere
indiana non è che mi entusiasmasse
ancora tanto perché dentro di me ero
convinta che fosse la mia origine
indiana essere diversa a di ad impedirmi
di farmi degli amici perché riesce a
relazionarti con gli altri solo quando
sai veramente chi sei tu
se non lo sai tu come fai a dirlo agli
altri se come speri che loro ti
capiscano se nemmeno tu sai cosa
dovrebbero capire e io non lo sapevo lo
sapevo che io fossi veramente ero sempre
più confuso e in questa confusione
arrivo il passaggio alle medie le medie
gli anni più brutti della mia vita come
per molti altri ragazzi perché si
diventa adolescenti si perde ancora poca
ingenua stupidità rimasta e mondo appare
così come con tutte le sue mancanze ei
suoi difetti
ci si sente persi sempre costantemente
sbagliati io che mi ero sempre sentita
sbagliata
mi sentivo ancor più sbagliata a volte
non era così grave ma ormai
psicologicamente mi ero convinta che
tutti mi volessero male quindi ogni
gesto ogni singola parola
riferiva che vivevo malissimo ricordo
ancora quando il professore decise per
la prima volta la disposizione dei
banchi disse il nome da ragazza che
sarebbe dovuta essere amia vicino di
banco vi giuro che posso ancora sentire
quel no schifato che urla lei dieci
minuti si lamentò perché non voleva
starmi vicino
ma il prof non vuole saperne di
cambiarle posto e forse fu meglio così
non penso sarei stata pronta a sentire
un altro no da parte dell'altra persona
che avrebbe dovuto prendere il suo posto
a peggiorare tutta questa situazione già
disastrosa che si misero pure i vestiti
con i genitori perché si sa a quell'età
è difficile andare d'accordo ma poi
quando si ha avuto un'infanzia in
adolescenza così diverse è ancor più
complicato i miei genitori è vero aveva
lasciato la casa per venire in un paese
diverse si erano rifatti una vita però
era ancor più complicato non sapere cosa
chiamare casa loro non potevano capire
come mi sentivo non avevano idea delle
difficoltà che affrontavo io perché loro
non si erano mai sentiti diversi erano
cresciuti in india in mezzo a tanti
amici che si erano fatti essendo
semplicemente se stessi
poi erano attorniati da nonni zii cugini
io invece qua non avevo altri parenti
oltre a loro e quindi loro poi non erano
cresciuti con le persone che ti
guardavano e scommettevano da quale
parte del mondo venisse loro non erano
soli perché loro probabilmente la
differenza di me erano nel posto giusto
però fu proprio perché ero suola che
inizia a stare più con me stesso
cercando di capire cosa avessi dentro e
per la prima volta ciò che mi rendeva
diverso mi sembra positivo notai la
ricchezza di avere due culture e la
notai come avrebbe potuto nata la una
ragazzina di 12 13 anni
ascoltando la musica e guardando i film
sì perché io mi resi conto che potevo
seguire la musica il cinema che seguono
tutti i miei compagni ma anche quelli
indiani e non ero costretta a scegliere
potevo fare quello che facciamo tutti
gli altri e addirittura di più scoprire
la bellezza della cultura indiana
mi diede nuova fiducia in me stessa e
finalmente le medie finirono era ora di
iniziare un nuovo capitolo della mia
vita
le superiori ricordo ancora il primo
giorno di liceo ero davanti all'ingresso
con mio babbo nettamente in anticipo
perché ho di essere in ritardo quando mi
si avvicinarono queste due ragazze e mi
chiesero 6 di prima loro se lo vorrà tra
le mie amiche più care e quel giorno
quel gesto fusi piccolo impacciato pieno
di imbarazzo ma mi ha cambiato la vita
loro non mi conoscevano eppure mi ha
rivolto la parola senza badare al colore
della pelle o il fatto che fosse
evidente che non ero italiano per la
prima volta mi ero sentita come tutti
gli altri
non diversa ma speciale è stato proprio
alle superiori che ho incontrato di veri
amici e ho capito che non era stata la
mia origine indiana ad avermelo impedito
semplicemente non lo avevo incontrato le
persone giuste quelle che mi
accettassero così com'ero lunatic piena
di dilemmi né indiana né italiano né
indiana né italiano per tutta la vita
mi aveva ripetuto che la vita è fatta di
scelte ma si erano dimenticati di dirmi
che si può scegliere di non scegliere lo
so sembra un gioco di parole invece è la
chiave di sforzo perché io mi ero
fissata che potevo essere o indiana o
italiana ma perché scegliendo solo una
delle due non sarei più stata io perché
tutte e due le culture sono parte
integrante di me e questo l'ho capito
crescendo
io ero e sono tuttora l'incontro di
queste due culture e la vera
integrazione sta nel trovare
l'equilibrio tra le due infatti non si
son dovuti di integrare solo i miei
genitori qui io mi sono dovuto integrare
con la mia stessa famiglia con me stessa
integrare non significa assimilare
un'altra cultura e sostituirla alla
propria quello significherebbe snaturare
se stessi no integrarsi suo vero
significato lo dice la parola stessa
integrare a sé incorporare e poi
diventare un equilibrista
certo non è sempre facile perché sono
due realtà molto diverse ma questo mi
spinge a trovare una mia originale
risposto ad ogni problema
una risposta che non è né la di un
indiana in quella di un'italiana ma è
realmente mia
la domanda è sempre stata chi sono io
beh io sono semplicemente io ma questo
io racchiude dentro di sé un mondo
intero e c'è voluto tanto per acquisire
questa consapevolezza perché prima ero
troppo piccola e perché la verità è che
tutto ciò che ho vissuto ogni crisi ogni
difficoltà
mi ha aiutato a diventare la persona che
sono oggi se avessi la possibilità di
rivivere miei anni passati non cambierei
nulla sono stati i propri momenti più
brutti che mi hanno aiutato a crescere
di più e crescendo ho imparato a
trasformare la fragilità in forza
scoprendo e valorizzando le ricchezze
dentro di me
il multilinguismo me dato maggiore
reattività e flessibilità
il multiculturalismo invece oltre a
farmi appassionare il look stravaganti e
gli abbinamenti di cibo particolari e
super piccanti sventata una maggiore
apertura verso gli altri
io amo scoprire cose nuove di culture
sempre diverse perché ognuna di queste
cose mi aiuta a capire qualcosa di me
qualcosa di quel mondo che ho dentro
appartenere a due culture diverse mi ha
aiutato ad avere una visione più
cosmopolita e non sapere quale paese
chiamare casa
mi ha fatto capire che io sono cittadina
del mondo
io quella bambina fragile come un
soffione mi sento oggi forte più che mai
sicura di poter fare tutto o almeno di
volerci provare
non mi sono mai arresa e mai lo farò ed
è proprio questo il messaggio che voglio
dare a tutti quei ragazzi che vivono una
situazione come la mia
certo non è un teorema che si possa
imparare a memoria ma qualcosa che si
impara vivendo però una volta acquisita
questa consapevolezza si cambia per
sempre e la vita diventano continua
bellissima scoperta di se stessi
e allora prendete anche voi un biglietto
di sola andata e venite insieme a me in
giro per il mondo a scoprire noi stessi
e il mondo che abbiamo dentro
shukri a grazie
[Applauso]